welcome back now in March the Chancellor
is expected to announce plans to cut tax
relief for pensions of high earners but
he's been warned it could deter people
from providing for a full pension for
themselves that comes alongside changes
to the state pension age which mean
women currently in their 50s some of
them will have to work until less 66 by
the end of this decade
well I'm joined now by the Labour MP
Frank field he's chair of the work and
pensions committee very good morning to
you mr. field let's start without
warning about the state pension in
particular a section of women who it
looks like it's going to get a raw deal
by the raising of the pension age I've
got a raw deal
maybe the labor governments at last
Labour government and then the coalition
government changed the pension age for
women and it particularly affects those
women born in the early 1950s and
particularly those towards the end of
the 54 55 there was a longest timetable
set out by the Labour government then
speeded up by the coalition in 2011 and
one of the questions which the campaign
was be is asking is where we actually
told and we've had day the Minister
before the Select Committee and we've
asked for what did you send out what did
the cut what did the Labour government
send out and to whom and what did you
send out telling women that the idea
they were marrying sorry Mary were
retiring at 50 at 65 60 was a no-go hmm
so what I mean just give us the sense of
you know what people can do and how much
it will cost them if they don't do
something about it or the government
doesn't relent it's the acceleration of
the increase in it's particularly acute
isn't it for women because they are
going as you say from 6266 yes I mean
that were initially the pension age was
being raised from 60 that was set in the
war to 65 to equalize and then there's a
moved to 66 for all of us the problem
that the members had have been before
the Select Committee of actually
highlighted is that they were not
probably informed about this and now
it's too late for them to work harder
save more
and therefore they face a retirement
which is totally unexpected to the
retirement that they actually thought
they were guessing so the pressure on
the government is what did the previous
Labor government say and what did you
say and did you tell all of this huge
number cohort group of women that their
pension expectations were being changed
and certainly evidence before the
committee shows people downsizing their
houses and the dream that they had of
retiring with their husbands of the
particular time is now almost null and
void that they'll answer there will be
real pressure on the government on that
and on the private pension site should
we feel any sympathy for those with big
pension pots that they're going to be
limited to only being able to save a
million pounds and might have there a
high rate tax relief of CO tailed it's a
good story to run and no doubt be
pressure on the government to justify
these privileges but there's a really
big story behind all of this and that is
over a long period of time we've given
pensions huge tax privileges money paid
into the pensions schemes are not tax
you tax when you're the penta money is
actually drawn out the cost to all of us
over the currently it's 27 billion
pounds and what I'd like the chance to
do is not have another go at limiting
this relief I'm in favor of him doing
that but saying this is the last big
chance we got doing something really big
with a huge tranche of money now there's
no way that you should actually
introduce this quickly it should be
phased in but if you think of no tax
relief and 27 billion pounds in a very
short period of time you could build up
a sovereign wealth fund for this country
we didn't do that with North Sea oil we
could do it with this and therefore when
people are talking about who pays for
high-speed - who pays for seriously
building houses instead of groveling off
to the Chinese we can actually use our
own money to be sort of self-contained
in that and people then see the real
benefits of the infrastructure
investments now tell me about you're
also writing today in there kind of
hands across the political divide since
with Sir Nicholas Soames as your
experience on balanced migration can
together warning the Prime Minister I
mean you just don't think he's asking
for not enough when it comes to
migration in his he you renegotiations
do you well I think John sergeant said
it just before the break in that when he
set off on this journey it was thought
to be brave to ask the limitation were
four years four people coming to this
country before they could draw welfare
benefits a year ago it was quite clear
that European Union as we now understand
is collapsing by the sheer weight of
numbers of people trying to get in and
share particularly Western European and
wealth therefore well before this
Nicholas Ames and I made a plea that we
should actually be able to restrict how
in fact impose our own borders to decide
the numbers actually coming in and when
you put that demand up against what the
Austrians are already doing the Germans
clearly will do even if it means
shifting mrs. Merkel then the idea that
we're just asking for a four-year ban on
drawing welfare benefits when all over
Europe boundaries and borders are going
up where people actually now are
frightened you had gained that was a
theme of the panel before the break
about fear and I find it amazing that
some highfalutin people should be saying
that politicians shouldn't reflect
what's going on in the country and there
is real fear about this and it will
unmake the European Union and we're
sadly now Prime Minister starting off at
the head of the game now is actually
behind it okay and what about your own
party I mean Jeremy Corbyn my colleague
faisal islam our political editor had a
long long chat with him there yesterday
as he visited one of the camps in Calais
and and one of the lessons that mr.
gorban seemed to be drawing from the
market beckett review into what went
wrong for your party in the general
election was so when it came to
migration that you failed to sing the
benefits of migration to the UK and mr.
Gordon mention contribution to the NHS
and and things like that is that the way
you say no not at all the real problem
we have is a new leadership which is in
touch with lots of economic injustice
--is but on some of the big issues about
the security of the realm of
defending our borders about defending us
ourselves if need be the Labour
leadership is walking off in the
opposite direction to where voters are
and particularly those swing labour
voters who didn't swing our way but
swung decisively engaged the government
it's unexpected election win last time
so that this is clearly going to be this
tension between
quite properly pitting on the economic
injustice is what do we do for people
towards the bottom end of which now
there's growing sympathy amongst the
electorate on which we're in tune but on
the big issues sadly which will decide
the next election which is about
defending our borders and defending us
as a nation the Labour opposition looks
as well walking in the opposite
direction and there clearly is going to
have to that's going to have to be
sorted out before the next election if
we're not to get us a wall up in the air
yet again Frank field thank you very
much thank you to see